mind your decisions I'm presh tal Walker
in semicircle a construct semi circles B
and C along the diameter of semi circle
a then construct circle D which is
internally tangent to semicircle a and
externally tangent to semi circles B and
C if the radius of semi circle B is
equal to 2 and the radius of semi circle
C is equal to 1 solve for the radius of
circle D this problem appeared on the
2017 AMC 12 a exam pause the video if
you'd like to give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
we begin with a preliminary result if
two circles are tangent their centres
and the tangent point are collinear to
see why draw a tangent line through a
Point C by definition AC will meet this
at a right angle and also BC will meet
this tangent line at a right angle
therefore ACB is a straight line and all
points a C and B are along the same line
this is true for externally tangent
circles and it's also true for
internally tangent circles returning to
the original problem will calculate the
radius of circle a recall that circle B
has a radius of 2 and circle C has a
radius of 1 therefore circle a has a
diameter equal to 6 and a radius that's
equal to 3 this means a B has a length
of 1 and AC has a length of 2 now
construct BD b d and it's tangent point
will be collinear therefore b - its
radius will be a distance of 2 and
suppose circle D has a radius equal to R
similarly construct DC this will be the
radius of D plus the radius of C now
construct a line through a D and the
tangent point between a and D this
entire length will be equal to the
radius of a which is equal to 3
since circle D has a radius of R the
distance between a and D will be 3 minus
R now let's just focus on the triangle
well clean this diagram up a little bit
and now we'll be able to calculate some
things from this diagram
we'll use al qasas law of cosines on the
entire triangle BDC and we'll label
angle c as theta now by L Kashi's law of
cosines the quantity 2 plus r squared is
equal to the quantity R plus 1 squared
plus 3 squared minus 2 multiplied by the
quantity R plus 1 multiplied by 3
multiplied by the cosine of theta
we can make a similar equation for
triangle ADC
now we can consider just these two
equations what we'll do is we'll
multiply the second equation by 1.5 this
makes sure that the term with cosine of
theta will be equal in both equations
when we subtract the second equation
from the first the cosine of data terms
will cancel out we then get a single
equation in one variable R we do some
careful simplification and we get some
magical cancellations the result is that
14 R is equal to 12 and therefore R is
equal to 6 over 7 and that's our answer
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on YouTube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
[Music]